ex-england cricket captain Michael
Vaughan has been cleared of racism
charges during his time at Yorkshire and
England and Wales Cricket Board charge
against him over an allegation that he
used racist language has been dismissed
by an independent Cricket discipline
commission panel so in its concluding
remarks on the allegations against Mr
Vaughn that see Cricket discipline
commission panel wrote the panel had to
consider whether the case as presented
to it by the ECB in light of all the
evidence was sufficiently accurate and
reliable on the balance of probabilities
to rule out mistake it was not as part
of a long statement on social media in
response to that decision Michael Vaughn
himself wrote at times this process has
brought me to the brink of falling out
of love with Cricket I won't address
here the toll it has taken on me and my
family but I have no doubt that it has
also been incredibly stressful for all
of the others concerned I hope that for
them and for Cricket an inclusive
healing process can now begin now that
the ecb's charge against me has been
missed I want to thank the panel for
their careful attention in very
difficult circumstances and to thank all
of those who've given me their support
during an incredibly difficult period in
my life